more than a million tons of radioactive
waste water could be dumped into the
Pacific Ocean as the grave warning from
Japan's Environment Minister where
authorities are still dealing with the
aftermath of the Fukushima nuclear
disaster the only option will be to
drain it into the sea and dilute it the
whole of the government will discuss
this but I would like to offer my simple
opinion a groundwater has accumulated at
the plant since the events of 2011
that's when a tsunami triggered multiple
nuclear meltdowns officials have
attempted to remove harmful pollutants
but a lot of them do remain and though
they are warning - that they'll run out
of storage space by 2020 - meanwhile the
government has spent something like 320
million dollars on a wall to slow the
flow of water to the reactors although
it's not what worked quite as well as
they had hoped tens of thousands were
evacuated from the Fukushima from
Fukushima sorry after the tragedy which
claimed the lives of more than 2,000
people according to Japan's
reconstruction agency but we spoke to a
nuclear expert about the ongoing dangers
people will be getting concentrated
radiation doses and seafood this is
extremely hazardous highly concentrated
radioactive waste water that will
bioaccumulate in the food chain and
humans are at the top of the food chain
it's not just Japanese people it's
anyone who eats seafood from the Pacific
Ocean that's why the South Korean
government is very concerned the United
States government should be very
concerned only now the Japanese
government is proposing to intentionally
release a million tons of highly
radioactive waste water that's a billion
liters of highly radioactive waste water
they should retain it they should store
it for 125 years let the tritium decay
away but there will still be other
radioactive poisons in there that have
to be filtered out and isolated from the
environment for much longer periods of
time
you